[Music]
back here in the valley the original
federal eviction moratorium was set to
expire next thursday but the cdc decided
to extend it another month
this of course helps tenants who can't
afford rent but tonight we hear from a
landlord who lost out on thousands of
dollars but is doing her best to help
tenants
victoria saha has the story the cdc says
this is the last time the eviction
moratorium will be extended
meanwhile the nevada state eviction
moratorium ended earlier this month
and landlords are still making up for
the loss of income
although the extension of the eviction
moratorium comes as good news for
tenants
landlords like julie brown are left
scrambling to pick up the pieces
when they're not collecting those rents
they're not able to pay their mortgage
they're not able to pay their
insurance they're not able to pay their
taxes it was a hard year for many
landlords like herself who owns
properties across the valley
and rely on tenants rent as income but
brown says she wanted to work with her
tenants so they wouldn't be left on the
streets
every person has a story every house has
a story every home has a story
and we forget that these are real people
that have real challenges and
oftentimes they're humiliated she helped
reduce the rent or come up with a
payment plan
but brown says some tenants took
advantage of the eviction moratorium
and didn't pay rent at all even when
they had jobs
at one property she lost more than 30
thousand dollars
i do rely on that money to live and if
all of them had said can't pay
that would have been disastrous in all
during the eviction moratorium brown
says she lost
close to 70 thousand dollars last year
but she hasn't evicted anyone as of yet
if you are a resident facing eviction or
are behind on paying rent
legal experts say you shouldn't wait
until the federal eviction moratorium
ends
to get help victoria saha 8 news now
free legal help is available at the
civil self-help law center